Hollywood has popularized the martial
arts. There were at least 10,000 people
who replied to the casting call for
Karate Kid Legends. That's right. The
global search for the star of our new
film starts right now. The concepts
presented in these films and TV shows
glamorize martial arts and the reasons
to fight and win. They justify the most
popular reason to learn martial arts,
self-defense. But if you take a closer
look, the concepts of light and dark are
being blended in these cinematic
portrayals. Many years ago, I spent 10
years training in kung fu. I reached my
second degree black belt. And as I share
some of my experience, let's explore
what this is really teaching. So, how
many of you grew up with the karate kid?
Not seen it. I've seen you the Jackie
Chan one. That's the Jackie Chan. Yeah.
Not the the original. Not the previous
ones. The previous like what was it?
Four. Was it three or four? I think.
Yeah. No, I've only wax on, wax off. No,
to me it was jacket on, jacket off. I
think that first released in 1984. That
was a big deal. That was the year my um
my second brother was born. Um I guess
my first brother, he's the middle child.
Um it was a big deal like Karate Kid,
you know, you know, it became kind of
like a a classic, you might say, in in
cinnamon. Then they went on to make
three films in that series with Daniel
Son, Mr. Miyagi. And then they made one
without him and it was with
um oh man Hillary Swank I want to say
and so just Mr. Miyagi and her and then
later they made a karate karate kid with
um Jackie Chan and Will Smith's kid
Jaden Smith when he was very young.
Yeah. And so now they've come out with a
new Karate Kid film, Karate Kid Legends,
and it has Daniel Son and No Mr. Miyagi.
It has Mr. Han, which was in the Karate
Kid with uh Jaden Smith. And they're
blending those two. And in between time,
there was a whole TV series, several
seasons, I think six seasons of a TV
series that revolved around this whole
anthology called Cobra Kai. So Cobra Kai
was part of the Karate Kid. It was part
of the original Karate Kid movies. That
was the competing dojo with Mr. Miyagi
and Daniel Son. It they were the the bad
guys, right?
So I want to show you the trailer for
Karate Kid Legends. This is the new film
that's coming out. And then we're going
to talk about some of these concepts in
this film and some of the other films
and some of the Cobra Kai stuff and see
where that puts us. Uh, as far as the
Bible goes. Okay.
You want to talk about it? My mom wants
us to leave everything behind.
Sometimes it is the only way to move
forward.
[Music]
You come to America. New rules,
new school, no fighting.
You study karate or something? Kung fu.
Used
to. I don't do any of that anymore.
Yeah, you're clearly over it.
[Music]
Who's your friend? Connor, don't start.
I couldn't be found. You really want to
do this?
You can't stop to guys like him. He wins
the five burrows every year. It's the
biggest tournament in the city. In life,
you have only one question. Is it worth
fighting for it or not?
Lee means to me what you meant to Sensei
Miyagi. I want Lee to learn Miyagi
karate. I'm sorry, Mr. Han. I I wish I
could help you. You will? I'm not coming
to New York. I will see you in the Big
Apple.
Sensei La Russo,
let's make a karate kit.
You have a foundation of kung fu. We're
going to build upon that with karate.
Ancient way.
Miyagi way. There's two of them. Focus.
This represents the history between the
two families. Two branches, one tree.
This is why I came to train
[Music]
you. Remember what you're fighting for.
When you understand that, you'll be
ready.
I was born
in survive.
Wow. Intense. It is intense. Yeah. So, I
grew up around this kind of stuff
because I spent um 10 years training in
the martial arts. Um what you have a
black belt, right? Second degree black
belt. I trained in a combination of two
styles, kung fu, sansu and shaolin. And
uh my dad was the one who taught me and
I I I pretty much grew around up around
this my whole life. I mean, I remember
watching when I was as young as, you
know, 3, four years old, my dad training
people and people coming over to the
house and working out outside, you
privately trained people and, um, it's
it's been in my family for a long time.
And I've had relatives that were also
involved in different styles as well.
Um, I guess you could call him a former
uncle. He was um, a practitioner of
Shodakon. His dad had a studio in
California and this kid, I mean, he grew
up training, you know, since he was a
baby. His dad like forming his fist and
all this kind of stuff. He went on to
gold medal in the Goodwill Games in
Calgary, Canada. And you had to fight
with like swords and everything, too,
right? Like all I did learn weapons
training. That was that was part of my
training. Um I don't know that all
martial arts learn weapons training. I
only had mostly exposure to kung fu,
some karate early on, but um I think my
brothers and I got kind of bored with
that. It was a lot very repetitive, at
least in the beginning, and we were like
kind of mentally checking out like,
okay, this is not not very much fun. And
so we we later on moved to the the kung
fu instead. In other words, Keith is not
someone to be messed with.
Yeah.
A lot of people tease that, but I'm I'm
really not not that way. So, what about
the animal kung animalistic kung fu or
whatever they call that? So, the animal
styles, there are many animal styles and
some of them are are specific branches
that was incorporated into my training.
So, it was, you know, you would learn
the monkey or the tiger. You would learn
aspects of that, you know, you would but
mostly for specific movements. So, for
example, um when you're doing some kind
of nerve strike, like say you want to oh
um hit somebody in the solar plexus,
right? This real soft area below your
rib cage, you know, at the top where
your stomach is, okay? You would form
your fist into a dragon's head is what
they would call it. Okay? And so, you
want to bury it in that soft spot,
right? It's real pointed because just
hitting it with a flat fist isn't going
to do as much damage, harm, have much of
a reaction. But if you can bury a
knuckle in there, they would call that a
dragon's head. Um, and there were there
were other movements. You learned
elements of crane and praying mantis and
monkey and tiger and snake and dragon
and all this kind of stuff. So yeah,
that that was all part of it. So I grew
up around all this and so whenever
movies would come out it was very
exciting. I remember when the Matrix
came out that was a that was a huge
deal. I was you know definitely right in
the middle of all the training and when
Keano Reeves said that move like or said
that line I know kung fu it was like it
was a big deal cuz kung fu wasn't as
prevalent I would say in mainstream
Hollywood at that point. There were a
lot of films that were karate based like
Karate Kid was probably more prevalent
in cinema during that time until until
that series came out and then it really
started to see a resurgence and
popularization of kung fu once
again. So, but he mentioned something
that I thought was interesting. He's
like he said and he was talking about
this in a different context, but he said
uh two branches, one tree, right? kind
of alluding to the fact that they're
part of the same family, kung fu and
karate. And this is a basic chart that
shows you the styles of martial arts and
which ones come from where. It's not on
this chart, but uh Miyagi do
karate is uh it's fictionalized in that
there is no Miyagi dojo. There is no,
you know, there's none all no Miyagi do
karate. But the style that's portrayed
in the karate kid movies that uh the Mr.
Miyagi teaches is a style most like
what's called Gojuru karate. And Goju
would have come from kung fu. It's a
more I guess direct, you could say
ancestor. It's not like several
generations removed. So yeah. Yeah. And
of course, the the the karate kid in the
karate kids legends, he's entering a
kung a karate tournament. So, it's kind
of like, well, why does he need to learn
karate if he already knows kung fu? And
this is like the the you know the
further back you know in in I guess
anthology you could say is we when
you're doing like point scoring karate
there are certain movements that you can
do that would be considered illegal or
could get you disqualified. Mhm. So it's
teaching him
basically, you know, certain certain
things that are okay in in a tournament
and certain things that are not.
Obviously, when you're not in a
tournament, it doesn't matter as much.
When people fight in real life is like
no holds barred. There's no rules.
There's no I mean I mean you're told in
in your training like if you got to bite
somebody, bite them, you know, poke
their eye out. There are some martial
arts that will teach you how to remove
the eye from the socket and pull it out.
Um, there's all kinds of, you know, hits
to the groin. I mean, there's this is
not but in point scoring karate, you're
not going to be able to do that, right?
I mean, this is a this is a tournament.
But pretty much in a in a real
confrontation, there's nothing that's
considered to be handsoff. Can you
imagine if they're like, "Stop, stop,
stop. That was illegal. You can't do
that." Yeah, definitely. Who are these
two people here at the top? Prince
Shotoku and Bodharma. Bodhi Dharma. That
was where Shaolin came from. So Bodhi
Dharma was an Indian. He traveled
through China. He came to these monks
that were in temples and he noticed that
they were very in poor physical
condition. And so he um I don't remember
if he wrote up a book or left a book
called muscle tendon training exercises
to like improve their health because
they were all into this
spiritual stuff. Mhm. But their physical
health was pretty bad. And so he
recognized being from
India there's a connection between these
two things. uh you need to combine this
training with the spiritual training and
yoke these things together for you know
the ultimate outcome. And so this is
really where and they started they
started doing those exercises from those
books and and is what eventually turned
into you know Shaolin kung fu and and
then of course from there Wo and Wing
Chong and all that kind of stuff. So
these like let's say uh are the ones
that are below the first line are things
that branched off. Yeah. So you're
you're seeing and also the ages of
different things. So like you know Wing
Chung around 1700 but then you say J
Kundo if you've heard of Jet Kundo
that's because this is what Bruce Lee
called his style of fighting. Bruce Lee
was a Jet Kundo practitioner. I mean,
not a G. He was he invented J Kundo, but
he was a Wing Chun practitioner. If you
go back in his history, that is what he
grew up learning how to do as Wing Chun.
And Wing Chun is is the one that's
popularized in all the films with the
Wing Chun dummy. It has two arms. It has
a leg. Uh your your trainer will swivel
this thing around or move things in and
out from it. And so you're learning to
block a wooden dummy, which is very
common in martial arts, especially kung
fu. They would use wooden apparatus or
um almost um yeah like wooden dummies.
Supposedly the Shaolin temple had a hall
of 108 wooden dummies that were
triggered for different movements and
different things. And so you're Shellon
priest. You had to go through this and
live in order to complete your training.
Isn't that funny? I'd be like the pastor
like you have to learn how to fight. you
know, that's that that's their religious
leader, right? Yeah. Well, there is a
documentary that came out a couple years
ago about where it was like pi church.
Yeah. Pastor versus pastor. So, we don't
want to get too far in the weeds all of
that. Um, but if you're super curious,
there's a couple there's a documentary
that we produced called The Dragon
Revealed. We'll have the links for you.
So anyway, most of the old kung fu
movies, and I saw quite a few of them,
they were full of the same kind of
elements that you saw in the trailer.
It's like family and tradition and honor
and all this kind of stuff, but there
was almost always one very common
element in all of them.
revenge,
right? Somebody killed somebody's
brother or sister or father or
something, you know, it's usually some
fight that happened. And so now you have
martial artist pitted against martial
artist and they must get supposedly that
honor and and family and and keep all of
that somehow by taking vengeance on
another person. Um, but I like what the
Bible says. If we were to put everything
in God's hands, would you mind reading
this text, Scotty? It's Deuteronomy
32:35.
Vengeance is mine and recompense. Their
foot shall slip in due time, for the day
of their calamity is at hand, and the
things to come hasten upon them. Romans
quotes this as saying, "Vengeance is
mine, saying the Lord, I will repay."
Mhm.
If we put everything in God's hands, we
don't have to pursue vengeance. We don't
have to pursue violence against another
person. We don't have to get our
revenge. We can leave it in God's hands
knowing that he is a better judge and
more just than we are. Mhm. So, I really
Does vengeance really make you feel
better? You know what I mean? Like the
key to actually overcoming some of these
things is forgiveness. And you know and
and you can look this up like there is
stories of the Holocaust people that
went through you know ashwitz and and
many of them like could never forgive
the Germans but then there's examples of
this one lady who was a manga twin and
she forgave them and lived a very nice
life. So yeah vengeance is for God and
it's not always our like duty to do
that.
Yeah. Yeah. And you'll see, you know,
I'm going to do another episode in the
in the near future. I'm going to sit
down with Eric Wilson, talk about my
experience in the martial arts, some of
the things that I came to realize kind
of at the end of my training and would I
pass this on to my children? Would I
continue to train people? What was going
to be my path in life? So, we'll talk
more about all those philosophies in an
upcoming episode. Um, but I just want to
touch on some things from the movies
because this is what people are
watching, they're seeing, they're
thinking it makes it look cool and it
glamorizes it, right? But at the end of
the day, something like vengeance is not
something that God wants us to espouse.
He wants us to forgive people, to let
things go, not hold on to them, you
know, can make you bitter. All right.
What I found very interesting is when
you look at this whole series and and
the Cobra Kai anthology and you start to
to look at that, there was actually a
scene in a church. I'm like, "Okay, this
is interesting. What's going to happen
here in the Cobra Kai?" In the Cobra Kai
series, and I don't remember what
episode or what season. And you're going
to have to bleep out some of the
language and the editing, but I'm going
to show you guys this clip. And I wanted
to get your feedback. I you know you
they haven't seen this before so this is
natural raw on LED live right we try to
do things as unscripted as possible
let's do it okay here we go forgive me
father for I have sinned
this this is where most of us go when we
think about forgiveness true yes but
what about forgiveness in other
forms forgiveness of others and then
there's my personal favorite forgiveness
of thyself
amen This is probably our toughest
battle. But listen, if God can forgive,
then so can you.
Oh, what about that time in Reno with
those soccer moms at the
Hyatt, Johnny? God forgive any of us for
that.
Yes, even that. Forgiveness is the very
core of Christianity. Well, I wouldn't
know about that. Not much of a church
goer. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Apologies,
everyone. My friend here is going
through some hard times. Nothing I can't
handle. Johnny, I'm in the middle of a
sermon. So, how about you take a seat?
You know, this guy was a real back in
the day. Fighting, drinking, partying.
Sucks. You're not allowed to get laid
anymore, man. How many times I got to
tell you I'm not a priest. So, your wang
can still get tang.
Forgive me, father, for what?
[Music]
That's how they started out the episode.
I don't know that that's how they
started out the episode, but it was in
one of the episodes. Interesting. Well,
it just makes the pastor and Christian
look like a bunch of hypocritical
nonsense to be honest. Like the way they
portray this. So, anybody who sees this
um might already have an idea of
Christianity as like bogus would be
like, "Yeah, that's just been confirmed
because of how it's portrayed." And and
that's that's that's
um that's sad because this, you know,
when somebody comes to Jesus
um like you have a history of you went
into the world, right? Partying and
drinking and all those kind of things.
Um, I would have full confidence in God
having worked in your life. When
somebody approached you like that, you'd
be like, "No, I'm going to this is not
my life anymore. I am forgiven and I am
going to continue with God and not go
back to that lifestyle." But now, first
of all, the character that walks in is
is making fun of the whole situation.
And then the guy is just like, "Oh,
forgive me for what?" and then he goes
back to his old life making it seem like
Christianity has no effect on anyone. It
also makes like him framing it in this
context like he's like shh be quiet
makes him feel like he's guilty or
trying to hide something and where you
know it's like true forgiveness is like
an erase from that thing right the
accuser is the devil. So that just made
him look like he still has things that
are happening behind closed doors. Yeah.
It's fascinating how they portray
Christianity here. Um, I I found myself
wondering why or should we should we do
something that we know we have to ask
forgiveness for like immediately. Good
point. It just doesn't
seem right. Right. Well, well, that's
more the idea in other aspects of I
guess Christianity where you go and you
confess beforehand what you're about to
do and then just go do it. That's not
genuine. But this isn't Catholicism
either. He said he's not a priest. Yeah.
And that's that's the interesting
factor. Like I said, like Christianity
here is completely misportrayed. Whereas
we all have experienced God's
transforming power in our lives and how
our we are not the same person and
there's power in someone's testimony,
right? Even the Bible even talks about
that. um because you can debate anything
but you can't debate someone's
transformed life because that's
evidence. And so here they're using that
most powerful aspect of a changed life
of Christianity and making it look like
that doesn't even exist or it's not even
real and that's a seed planted against
God in this. I just think it's it's
interesting that you know like you said
is he really is he really asking for
genuine forgiveness before committing
the act?
No, it's like, "Oh, forgive me for
what?" And then he doesn't. It's like,
"Oh, yeah." You know, he kind of wanted
to do it. Yeah. So, I want to show you
the followup to this, or at least part
of it, okay? Cuz there's a a scene after
this where they're sitting together and
get your feedback on this about the
pastor's advice. I still don't
understand how they get the coffee in
the cake.
Johnny, what the heck was that all
about? I know you're upset, but you
can't blame yourself for what Robbie
did. I'm not even allowed to see him.
Not allowed since I'm on probation for
that little incident in the uh parking
garage. Yeah, well, you're lucky it was
only probation. I'm lucky I knew a
priest. Put in a good word with the
judge. Thank you very much. Not a
priest.
How about we make a deal? You promise
yourself to do positive things. Be a
better person.
I already tried that. I put everything I
had into my students. I taught them to
be tough and show mercy.
Thought I was doing the right thing. You
were? Yeah. Then why did all this
happen? I mean, you want to punish me?
Fine. Robbie and Miguel, they're just
kids. I know. I know. It isn't
fair. You got to remember, you don't do
the right thing because it always works
out. You do the right thing because it's
the right thing to
do. Both those kids need you, and you
need to be there for them, whether it
works out or not. What do you think
about his advice?
I mean, he's he's he's giving him advice
to do the right thing, but then he just
demonstrated that he didn't do the right
thing. Yeah. And so, it kind of makes
you feel like like, you know, listen to
my words, don't don't do what I do. Mhm.
This is a I think it's a very typical
example of Hollywood trying to kind of
cozy up to Christianity, but not really.
He told him he needed to do good
things, right? and he told him that he
needed to
um he said good things and then you need
to be a better person. It's a perfect
opportunity to share how that process
works. Like how are you going to do good
things and how are you going to be a
better person? Is the power all in him?
Obviously he walked in with his life
screwed up. So how is he going to do it?
And he said oh I already tried being a
better person. Yeah. He already admitted
his own failures. enter opportunity to
say, "You need to turn your life over to
Christ. Here's a Bible. Let's start
reading it and show you how this works."
Yeah, good point. And he has the full
opportunity. He's a pastor, but yet
that's not being spoken of because
that's the power of the gospel. The
power of the gospel that is actually
changes your life. And you you can
overcome your sinful behavior through
Jesus Christ, through his sacrifice, and
not continue to walk in those old ways.
But here, like you said, he's given a
full opportunity, and that's not the
message that Hollywood wants to put out.
They they give it like a rundown milky
version of it instead of the full meal.
Mhm. Yeah. So, my point in showing these
is to show the contrast between how, you
know, there's this vengeance aspect
that's being put forth in the movies and
the TV shows that Hollywood does. But
when it comes to the Christianity
aspect, it's kind of a token nod. like,
"Yeah, we know it's part of society, but
there's nothing really there." So,
they're emphasizing the one, emphasizing
the fighting, emphasizing that, and
glorifying that, but minimizing the
other. And so, that's really right. I
included
those. Okay. Going to show you a couple
other things. And most of these I'm
going to show you the probably the full
clip just so you have context. Okay? And
it's a couple minutes long. This is you
might remember this guy John Crease as
his character from the original Karate
Kid movies. He was the one that owned
the competing dojo, the Cobra Kai dojo.
Point hit him again.
Do you have a problem with
that? A fight isn't over until your
enemy is
finished. You show your enemy no mercy.
Wait. This isn't what Sensei Lawrence
has been teaching us.
Excuse me. There's no honor in being
merciless. Tori scored a
point. It's
[Music]
over. Sensei Lawrence is right. Of
course, in a tournament, the fighting
stops when you land a
point. But in the real
world, it's not about scoring points.
It's about being a
winner or a loser. And there are no
losers in this dojo.
Is this what you were taught in when you
did martial arts? The same concept?
No. But and I'll and I'll cover this
more thoroughly um when I do a program
with Eric.
Bottom line is you're going to see a lot
of inconsistencies in philosophy. Mhm.
So in here, this is the competing dojo
and so they're the bad guys. So you
expect them to be like no mercy, you
know, nothing like that. Well, what
about the good guys? What kind of
philosophy do they have? Or is it less
black and white and more mixing of the
two and more gray? Mhm. Okay. It in the
in the original series, this is way more
black and white when but like Star Wars,
like the original films more black and
white, but then when Disney took over,
it started to get all mixed together and
more gray. And so you have these
characters that are like both. They're
using the force, but then they're also
dabbling in, you know, um the Republic.
Yeah. They're they're the dark side of
the Force, right? mixing the two. You
see the same thing with the Cobra Kai
series. Those black and white
characters, they're now gray and
tarnished and it's confusing and you
don't know what's right and it's kind of
putting people up for these moral
dilemmas. It seems like that's what
Satan wants in our minds as well though
to have that confusion about moral
dilemmas and like do you know blending
what's right and wrong to give you just
a little bit of both so that you know
you don't have the full purity of good
and you just kind of fall into by the
wayside really you also have like the
ten commandments being you know how you
see God and then the other six how you
see man and your relationship to them
and I don't know if there's any place in
the Bible that's like you know be him to
a pope till they're finished. I mean,
yes, God executed judgment and he used
his people to do that, but you know, not
in this sort of sparring way, maybe. And
that's an argument people will bring
forth. They'll say, you know, well, God
said, wipe out the Amalachites, all of
them. And so, they look at that as like
a no mercy type concept. But God says of
himself that he is merciful and
gracious. Denique, would you mind
reading this from Hosea 66? For I desire
mercy and not sacrifice and the
knowledge of God more than burnt
offerings. God is a merciful God. And so
the way this is portrayed, yeah, it's
supposed to be the bad guys and make
them look bad, but it's also supposed to
look pretty cool, you know, like, yeah,
you want to be a winner, you know, and
so being a miss a winner is being
equated with no mercy, you know, you
just got to finish it off. Yeah. And if
you if you spare them or show kindness,
you're a loser. And also they're
alluding to this like well there's a
difference between a tournament and a
real life situation. The reason why God
desires mercy and not sacrifice um and a
knowledge of God more than burnt
offerings is because the burnt offering
was you know it was a symbol of Christ
who was to come who was going to die for
our sins. And ideally God didn't want
you to end up having to sin and
therefore having to take to make the
sacrifice. He wants you to bestow mercy
in the first place. Mhm. And have
knowledge of God in the first place and
God is love. Knowledge of God. God is
love. Instead of getting to the point
where I have sinned and now um I have to
make a burnt offering. So it all goes
step back to like God wants to change
our hearts and change our lives so that
through his power we can be merciful to
begin with instead of ah Lord I need
forgiveness because I didn't.
Absolutely. and
break your
Jacob and he formed you
Israel. I will make him a pillar in the
temple of my God and he shall go out no
more. I will ride on him in the name of
my God.
Be strong in the Lord and in the
power shall strength. He shall mount
up like heels. He shall run and
not pray alone.
But by every word that proceeds from the
mouth of
God. All right. Now, here I want to
here's where I want to show you. These
are now the good guys, right? This is um
Daniel's son that everybody's come to
know. Now he's his older and he has his
own, you know, he's taken over Miyagio
as a as a teacher. But this guy that
he's training with is somebody he faced
off against in Karate Kid 2, who was the
villain. His name is Chosen. C H O Zen,
but they call him Chosen. And you will
start to see how these lines between
what's right and wrong start to blur
because you know Cobraai says no mercy.
Well, what about Miyagi? It's only for
self-defense, right?
Are you sure you just don't want to show
me the scrolls?
Now, let us see how much you really
know. I don't know what you want.
What the hell?
So, your sensei did not teach you
everything. Are you sure that was Miyagi
Dokarate? Didn't seem like self-defense
to me. Defense takes on many forms.
The Miyagi ancestors fought Japanese
invaders. The only way to survive was to
kill.
Soyagi instructors came up with special
techniques designed to kill their
enemies.
[Music]
Mr. Miyagi never told me about any of
this. Maybe he thought you are not
ready.
are not able. Maybe Mr. Miyagi was just
trying to protect me. We're not living
hundreds of years ago. No reason anymore
to kill.
Sometimes you have no choice but to
kill. What did you do?
Honk.
[Laughter]
I'm glad you're having fun at my
expense. You should have seen your face.
What technique was that?
My limbs were totally numb. Secret
Miyagi pressure
points. If an enemy insists on war, then
you take away their ability to wage
[Music]
it. Can you teach me?
Is this an actual physical thing or is
this where like the chi power which
really we understand as demonic power
comes in? No, there are things that are
like that that you can do to people that
um at least temporarily disable.
So it's not it's not some necessarily
mystical thing or anything like that.
There's a lot of physics involved in
martial arts training. So for example,
if you I'll just use the example of
solar plexus earlier. If you hit
somebody in the solar plexus, okay, the
physical response is that their hands
are going to go for their stomach and
they're going to start to double over,
right? Like, you know, they're going to
feel it. Knowing that, the next
movements are designed to attack the
parts of the body that are now more
vulnerable. Mh. Okay. So, it's really
there's a lot of it that's been really
thought out physiologically and they
know that, you know, action reaction.
So, if you're now bent over or, you
know, partially bent over and your hands
are here, well, your hands are not up to
protect you. Get the head. So now, yeah,
your throat's exposed, your head's
exposed, or, you know, or other parts of
your body. you might swoop around back
and and start to, you know, work on
their kidneys or something. So, yeah, a
lot of things are like that. Interesting
that they're wearing like black and
white. Why is the sensei wearing a black
outfit? Is there a reason for that?
They're technically both supposed to be
black belts. If you're looking at Daniel
Son, he has a black belt on. So, they're
supposed to be like kind of same, you
know, same. The color of the of the
Well, the color of the belts and this
this I mean, as far as I ever knew, the
lore kind of went this way. Um, when
this comes from karate, and when um the
Okinawans were invaded and they they had
monks helping them train, Shaolin monks
helping them train to learn how to
defend themselves and things like this.
as they trained over time, their belts
and their clothing changed colors
because of being thrown in the dirt or
the grass or whatever. So, you would go
from the white to yellow to green to
brown to black. And other styles have
incorporated other colors in between,
but that's the basic gist of it. In
other words, the longer they trained,
the more soiled and dirty their garments
became and the more proficient they
were. That's spiritually interesting. It
is very spiritually interesting because
white is so symbolic of purity, of
righteousness, of you know, the bi I'm
looking at this through the the lens of
Christianity like like doesn't really
make a lot of sense if you don't even
understand or know what the Bible says.
But if if if we start out with this, you
know, whiteness and then you get to the
black parts, our good deeds are like
filthy rags, right? We are dirty and
black and the only way that we get
covered again is with the robe of
Jesus's perfect righteousness. Wash me
and I'll be whiter than snow. Psalm 51.
Yeah. So, it's weird that you live this
lifestyle and aim at getting the black
part. Yeah. The knowledge that you've
obtained by that point is darkness. Mhm.
and deception.
See, they were they were blending the
ying and the yang right there just in
their outfits, you know? It's like you
could see the black and white. So now
you see
Daniel's, you know, his whole like,
well, I thought this was all black and
white and karate is just for
self-defense and this guy that he fought
once upon a time who learned
from the he has the same karate lineage,
Miyagi do karate. He's also saying,
well, you don't know everything. Mhm.
And sometimes you have to kill.
And then he defeats him and and now he's
like, I need to learn from you. Mhm.
Well, why? He just also said, you know,
people aren't trying to kill each other
hundreds of years, you know, later.
Like, it's not a matter of life and
death. And you see how they're blending
the concepts and mixing the concepts and
blurring the lines. Okay. So, let's take
um a look at this because you'll start
to see how this uh also is in their
opponents.
Shika,
what? What is it? I have seen these
moves before. You have? Where? Kim
Seongyang.
Excuse me. My name is Terry Silver. My
master is Kim Seongyang of South Korea.
My teacher sends his respect. Kim
Seongyang was master of a tongudo but
that is not what he taught. His style
was um controversial. What was
controversial about it?
I will
demonstrate. Kimongyong style is based
on deception.
No honor, no mercy. You could have just
told me. If Silva is student of Master
Kim, we must be careful. All direct
attacks will be recognized. I don't want
to attack him. I want to expose him.
To catch Serpent, he must think like
Serpent. We will use his style against
him. How will we do that?
Yeah. Once again, like you know, in a
Christian
context, that's like telling a Christian
to beat the opponent who's using
deception and and things that are wrong.
We must use deception and things that
are wrong but to basically win them.
It's interesting when you study the
martial arts.
Um these are things that you learn are
exposed to. For example,
SunSu said, and all warfare is based on
deception. You're like, well, who is
this sonug guy? Right. Um Ralph Sawyer
comments on his book, The Art of War,
because um he's writing about the seven
seven ancient military classics of
ancient China. He says, "For the last
2,000 years, it remained the most
important military treat in Asia where
even the common people knew it by name."
This is a very common book, very common
knowledge. Like this would have been in
wide circulation. The book, The Art of
War, The Art of War. Okay. What'd he
say? All warfare is based on deception.
When I got to my black belt lessons, I
was told that the what they were named
meant deception because the way you were
going about your movements was designed
to make your opponent think you were
going to do one thing and then you do
something
else. So, the Civil War people did not
get this book. No, they stand in a line
and just each other. No, they did not.
It's also interesting. This is kind of a
side note interesting that in his book
Ralph Sawyer also said this book was
first translated into the French
language in 1772 by French Jesuit Jean
Joseph Murray Emmois. Interesting. Yeah.
Walter V. He does a series that I
watched a few weeks ago. He makes very
strong connections between the art of
war and and the Jesuits. Very very
strong evidence for it. There are many
books uh that are written like this. For
example, there's the book of five rings.
Have you ever heard of this? Mhm. It's
widely read actually in a lot of
business circles, but it's a it's an
older book. It was written by uh
Miiamoto Mousashi, and he was a
swordsman. And so he wrote a book called
The Five Rings on his tactics and the
way you're supposed to think and behave
and all this kind of stuff. And people
take that stuff and they apply it to
today's world. So a lot of ancient
stuff, but makes its way into modern
society. But all warfare is based on
deception. Very interesting
statement. Would you mind reading this,
Felipe? It's Revelation 12:9. So the
great dragon was cast out, that serpent
of old called the devil and Satan who
deceives the whole world. He was cast to
the earth and his angels were cast out
with him. It's pretty fascinating that
two things started with
Satan. Deception. Mhm. And war. And what
did Sun Su say? All warfare is based on
deception. Satan's the author of war.
Mhm. The Bible also has some things to
say about that. It says in Psalm 101:7,
"He who works deceit shall not dwell
within my house." This is essentially
God speaking. He who tells lies shall
not continue in my presence. So we are
not supposed to be deceptive in any way.
Not in our business, not in the way we
communicate with our kids, not the way
we interact with our co-workers. That's
not how God operates. God is completely
transparent and God lays everything out
on the table and he says, "Look,
investigate." I mean, I'll show you
everything I've
done. No deceit. Another interesting
aspect I I saw they were working in also
into the Cobra Kai series. This is the
character Terry Silver. Um, you saw him
earlier in the last clip fighting. He's
actually a real martial artist. His name
is Thomas Ian Griffith. Um, so is the
guy who plays Chosen and he was a
partner with John Crease in the in the
Karate Kid series. They owned the Cobra
Kai studio together. He's more like the
rich financier playboy type, but also
martial artist. And in the third movie,
he comes in and he trains Daniel's son
and befriends him and all of this kind
of stuff, but all under a false
pretense, a false guys. What does the
name Daniel mean? My God is my judge.
Yeah, my God is my judge. Is it
interesting that his name is Daniel? So,
it is. It is. Let's leave that for the
deep thinkers. Yeah. Mhm.
So here he once again meets his friend
from a long time ago and they have an
interaction. But it's fascinating what
they work into this in the series. So
we'll show you guys this.
So I figured why not create an app where
kids in places like Ohio for example can
learn it for themselves. Ah I'm sure
kids would love that. Terrence and I
have a history of teaching children with
martial arts. Oh, that's right. You did
mention something about a karate team
once. Um, what was it called again? The
Vipers.
Cobra Kai. That's adorable. I had no
idea you had a karate face. Karate is
not a phase. It's a way of
life. You can leave it for a while.
But it never really leaves you.
We all have anger inside. Once again, I
think I'm I'm I'm looking at this just
making a comment through the the the
spiritual eyes because um we are
supposed to if we feel like something is
wrong. We ask for forgiveness. We
understand that the Bible is saying that
thing is wrong. We are supposed to put
it away and not return to it. And I
think this kind of just leaves this this
door where it's just like, yeah, you're
never going to really solve this. Yeah.
When you are martial arts practitioner,
um you could say there's some truth to
this. It's not like a gun where you can
just put it away, right? It really
becomes part of your life, part of who
you are, and it goes with you everywhere
you go. So, even in my own experience,
and I'll get into this more in a future
episode,
um, you develop mindsets. I used to
constantly size people up when I walked
into a room, especially males. I'd look
around like, I can take that guy. I can
take that guy. I can take that guy. And
you just, you're looking at them,
looking at their bill, looking at how
they move, you know, trying to
determine, have they ever been a martial
artist? And you you learn to pick up on
small things that will tell you those
things. And you you just you just have
this mindset of, you know, I can defend
myself. I I can. But the thing is,
there's nobody just outright attacking
you. There aren't people jumping out
from the hallways. You know, the way
they portray it in in movies and films,
it's like you got to be on constant
watch cuz there's just somebody right
around the corner ready to, you know,
smack you over the head. It's not like
that in real life. Yeah, it's extremely
rare for that to happen in real life. It
is rare. But I can see like you're
saying it it becomes so all absorbing
that
um that that's all you can think of. You
think about it all the time and that's
not the way Christ wants us to think all
the time. I remember when we did that
documentary with Eric Wilson, he said
something that just stuck with me from
the beginning was basically like if you
have, you know, 20, 30, 40 years of
training and let's say you get into an
altercation at this age, what are you
going to rely on? If you've had all this
training, your your training is going to
come to the surface and you're going to
deal with the problem. Whereas like God
in the end of time is asking for us to
completely and utterly 100% rely on him.
M so if you don't have a gun in your
pocket, the only thing that that you're
going to do to make it out of that is,
"Lord, protect me." And you're putting
that protection in God's hands rather
than selfdefense, if that makes sense.
Because a lot of women will take karate
because they say, "Well, what if a man
comes at me?" And I thought it was
really interesting. Eric brought this
out in that documentary, too. He said,
"Listen, if somebody is coming at you
that is drunk, high, whatever, he's not
fighting fair to begin with. So it
doesn't matter how much training you
have, it's going to be a difficult fight
for you to take that man out. And he
said you can just resolve it with a can
of mace. Yeah. So like you have 20 years
of training or can of mace. Many people
who do that and I and you know there are
many people who put on raperevention
seminars and I have no
um I'll say this, I understand why they
do it. I think it is a good thing to
want to protect women and children and
and and and just people in general. I
but um a lot of those seminars are
better served when they focus on aspects
that women can control
regularly. When you're you go to a rape
prevention seminar to learn martial arts
techniques, you're at risk for doing
those techniques wrong because you don't
practice them all the time. You're going
to leave that seminar. you're going to
go home and you're not going to practice
that stuff all the time. It's going to
be a rare individual that practices that
all the time. You are at risk for being
outweighed by somebody else by probably
50 to 100 pounds. That's a lot of
weight. And um especially when it's you
know somebody who's drunk or high and
it's more like dead weight, you are you
are also better served by learning
things that just keep you out of the
wrong place at the wrong time,
right? And the Bible already teaches us
those things. You know, there are places
that Christians should find themselves,
places and times and places and times
that they should not be found. So, for
example, if you're a woman, large city,
even some small cities, it's not wise to
be out late at night by
yourself. It's kind of just inviting an
opportunity for a problem, right?
Because we know there are people who are
up to no good. That's usually the hour
that they find themselves up to no good
right late at night. So if you need to
go out, take somebody with you. Take a
friend, you know, take a boyfriend, take
a husband, somebody, so that you don't
put yourself in an awkward situation
because those kind of people are praying
on the one person who's alone, right,
that they think can't do anything about
it. So anyway, and yeah, canace, it's a
good thing.
So, we'll get into more of that in a in
a future episode. Fascinating though,
she started talking about mindfulness
and meditation and all that kind of
stuff, right? This is actually common in
the martial arts as well. Some martial
arts, they will teach you about things
like meditation and how to, you know,
empty your mind. In fact, uh most of
them will talk about this concept called
key. Some people call it chi. It's key.
And a lot of it has to do with breath
control, but really it's ultimately
learning how energy is focused through
your
body, which is just like, well, why do
you need that, right? Martial arts is
very esoteric in that in the entry
level, you will learn things and then as
you get further and further along, you
learn more and you learn more and you
learn more and you learn more, just like
in Freemasonry. And the next thing you
know it's like, well, yeah, that breath
control from the very beginning. Yeah,
that was just a start to get you to
energy
manipulation. Okay. So, you think from
the the from the bottom tier like, oh,
this is all just harmless. You know,
you're learning breath control. It's
just like lama or something. Okay. But
the more you get into it, the more you
find out it's not just breath control.
Mhm. Okay. a lot of esoteric things like
Echart Tulli is always talking about the
introduction into this as breath work
and you know he's a super spiritualism.
So yeah so the martial arts yoga the new
age these are all related on these
concepts. Yeah, I remember when I
watched the Dragon Revealed, our our
martial arts documentary for the first
time and and towards the end of part
one, which is for free on YouTube, um
Eric talked about key um and and how he
explained that the whole time he heard
about it, but they were like not really
telling him what it was. And it was like
when I think when he became a disciple,
which I think is above black belt,
right? Like the next step from my
understanding. Um he said that's when
they told him and he realized having a
Christian background he's like that's
demonic possession and that's when they
can like you know uh chop through like
bricks and when they can levitate and do
all of these things and he was like I'm
out. I'm done. Mhm. You also find it um
people commenting on these concepts like
Bruce Lee for example he said empty your
mind be formless shapeless like water.
If you put water into a cup it becomes
the cup. If you put water into a bottle
and it becomes the bottle. You put it
into a teapot it becomes the teapot. Now
water can flow or it can crash. Be
water, my friend. You see how he started
that out?
You know, empty your mind. He understood
those concepts are taught in many
martial arts, that meditation aspect.
You may not get it from the very
beginning or you may get it from the
beginning in a different form, a form
you don't recognize, but it's very much
like yoga or other things like that.
You're going to start out here and
you're going to get a a steady drip of
those concepts as you move move further
and further along. Yeah, empty your
mind. Like what? Empty your mind, which
the Bible speaks against speaks against
because a specific story where Jesus
says, you know, don't leave your house
empty because the demons will come in.
Exactly. That's exactly what's happening
here. And we see this over and over like
in yoga as well with um blessings. She
was a famous former yoga instructor and
she learned later on that yeah, if you
go into the hardcore yoga, the whole
purpose of this is to empty yourself so
you can get possessed by demons that
will take over, which is part of kalini
yoga. But but Keith, you kind of alluded
to this already, but some people might
say, "Oh, well that's the higher up
levels, right? Like that's when you
don't delve with into key and demonic
possession. Surely I can start off
having my kid train in martial arts and
none of this will be part of that. Is
that true? Um I have not found it to be
true in my experience and I've not seen
it true in any other martial arts. I
know there are people who claim well you
you can just separate all that stuff
out. You just learn the physical
movements over here and and keep all
that spiritual stuff over here. It
wasn't overtly spiritual in my training.
And so I didn't get a lot of that, but
on the backside of it, I
recognize how it was
incorporated without even thinking about
it. You know, it was just it was just
part of it. You learned it and then when
you look back, you're like, "Oh yeah,
that's that's how it was brought in."
You know, this kind of stuff. So it's
not always easily recognized from the
get-go. And from the beginning, it may
not be in your entry. It may not be in
your entry level, but that's just how
Satan works, right? Yeah. I mean, how
how many It's free. How many other
religions or esoteric religions or forms
of it have that like bottom level layer
where they're like, "Oh, it you can be
still be a Christian or you can still do
this and it's all okay and it's all
we're all brotherhood. We're all
friends." But it's like a way to pull
you in. So once you get closer you
slowly there's that drip like you said
and there are many quotations you'll
find from a lot of people who have done
this their entire lives. Mhm. And
they'll they will tell you you can't
separate these things. In fact they will
emphasize that the spiritual components
are more important than the physical
components. Right? You'll find that in
the martial arts. You'll find it in yoga
as well. Same kind of quotations from
people who are lifetime practitioners
who have studied this, you know, since
they were kids. Same kind of thing. They
will both tell you in both instances,
the spiritual is more important. The
physical stuff is only a means to get
you to the spiritual and that's what you
really need to be doing. And that's
actually true of a lot of sports. You
can be physically good, but a lot of the
game is actually played in your head.
And the better that you know the the
mindset of that game, the better you'll
be. I mean, there's a lot of very
talented athletes. So, yeah, it's kind
of across the all those genres of of
sporting things. That's kind of what
seems like it determines the better
players. And what is the ultimate
spiritual goal with martial arts? Like,
what do they tell you is the ultimate?
What are you actually trying to achieve?
Probably it's going to be a little
different depending on what martial art
you're in, but they're they're not I'll
say this. prior to a black belt. They're
not probably going to come at you with
any spiritual
goal, at least not overtly. It's only
probably when you get to that black belt
and beyond that they're going to start
really focusing on those spiritual
concepts as a point of emphasis. What
would the goal be? Um, they're very much
the same way as things as like in the
new age or yoga. like be one with the
universe, be one with yourself. Um,
learn how to have mastery over yourself
or what's around you. It's that it's
that kind of stuff. It's not they're not
going to
say
overtly you're here to be a god. It's
not like that. It's more it's more
there's more of an undercurrent to it
than that. It's more it's more usually
about being one with what's around you
or being one with yourself. And I think
Eric described it as being able to um
manipulate objects or move people
without touching them. I mean, can you
imagine fighting somebody if they can't
even touch you, but you're able to fight
with them? Like, that's probably the
goal of all of them to basically have
that much power that they could take
care of the situation without actually
any physical contact. Mhm.
So, let's I want to end land on uh this
um verse from the Bible here. And this
is from Joshua 18. Would you mind
reading this, Scotty? Because it talks
about meditation. So, what are we
supposed to be meditating on? And how
does that work? This book of the law
shall not depart from your mouth, but
you shall meditate on it day and night.
And that you may observe and do
according to all that is written in it.
for then you will make your way
prosperous and then you will have good
success.
In order to meditate on something the
way the Bible's talking about, your mind
has to be full. You have to be thinking
about those things because if you're not
thinking about them, you can't do them.
Mhm. Right. So, this is the difference
between the Bible and what it what it's
getting at with meditation. And it's
filling your mind with God's word and
thinking about that how it plays out in
your life versus meditation in other
forms is about emptying your mind and
then letting whatever come what may into
your
head. So big difference. So those are a
few of the concepts. We'll cover more in
a future episode with Eric Wilson. I
talk more about my own personal
experience and training and some of the
realizations I came to. But the movies,
TV shows, they like to make martial arts
look glamorous and cool and all that,
but really there's some things that
you're being taught that are not cool
and they're not from
God. If you like this video, like,
subscribe, and hit the notification bell
so you know when we launch new videos
and drop a comment below and we'll try
to get back to you if we can. What?
Say that again. Oh, no. I don't know
what to say.
[Music]